you know
hello
someone
hey Lucas
hey Jojo hey Hufflepuff
hey sit in say Arc Bryce jpez mod Josh K
Owen
random guy Isaiah
JP
Senora Leo the Typhon
Evan
welcome
can you guys uh hear me okay
smeagoli skit Santana
hello hello
foreign
how's everyone doing
levels are good good
good good
Bryce production Super Chat did you know
that Robin Williams wanted to play Remus
Lupine uh I didn't know that I know that
he
was considered for Hagrid but JK Rowling
wanted all British actors
do you guys think uh Robin Williams
would have made a good Hagrid
so frustrating
you wanted to speak with me mother
as good as Robbie now speak with you
alone I don't think anyone can do as
well
you know what it was let's say I am
allowed favorite franchise besides Harry
Potter
um
I don't know maybe Lord of the Rings
the first one that comes to my mind
no I haven't finished the game I do not
want you visiting
who's still waiting for the game any of
you guys too much not meddled in the
Affairs of dangerous people
I'm a Star Wars fan but uh
maybe my in my top five I must get to
class
I'm not Star Wars Theory
so frustrating
she never listens to me she called you
her little gazelle
is that a term of endearment where
you're from it is specific to me
what about you guys what are your um top
three franchises
is not taught at Hogwarts so I am gently
discouraged from practicing it
however
I am an Anna Marcus hello hello this is
in my gazelle form that I have been able
to wander the highlands rather freely
until now
much to my mother's Chagrin that is how
I managed to spy on Rookwood and Harlow
it's a shame that DC isn't being handled
very well
I feel like DC has been mishandled the
films just have all been flops
as far as I'm concerned
um but I do like DC so it's a shame
yeah Dragon Ball Z I'm a big Dragon Ball
Z fan actually
now the nickname makes sense
what an extraordinary ability I haven't
watched uh Naruto I love transforming
mother is less enthusiastic
especially one as rare as a gazelle
should be bounding about the typhoon you
should complete the game why not why
would you stop you're so close for sin
tragedy before me in my gazelle form but
she has used her sight to control me too
many times I no longer believe it
sorry I'm just a bit distracted here for
a second hold on
I wish Hogwarts Legacy had updates yeah
um I mean it's still early days right it
hasn't even come out on
many different platforms so
I think you know
six months after it's released on the
other platforms we could probably expect
some
DLC I mean maybe that's just wishful
thinking I don't know
we're making good progress we can't quit
now I agree I have never considered
quitting even you guys hear background
noise they're living in a department
building like the moment you discovered
that Rookwood yeah
after you but you did not and you're all
my recording at night you have I must
deal with Rookwood and Hollow not hide
from them
my mother can
thank you for being here during that
rather awkward conversation
what is this
hi Morgan
so thanks for stopping by
rebelio
what do we have here
damn you guys
professor
could you remind me of the purpose of
the assignments you set for me see in
the future is only part of what I teach
my students they must also be prepared
for what the future may hold hence the
need for you to complete certain tasks
as part of your education when you have
finished the tasks return to me and you
will be able to learn I haven't finished
the game yet
I think that even though this game
is single player
it's kind of
proven that Harry Potter games can
succeed so this is just kind of the
beginning
no I'm not Star Wars Theory
he's a partner on the channel but uh
we're just friends
we are different people
I'd better keep an eye on high places
around the school for zenobia's
gobstones
hi hbt big fan of your content I was
wondering if you could bring back the
old background music using your videos
around 2020.
um which one are you referring to
Jim met first time catching online love
the channel you're doing great job thank
you thank you
games and movies entertainment I have to
go now enjoy your content hbt have fun
this is a great game thank you thanks
for coming by revelio
I should do an interesting Quest because
otherwise you guys are going to get
bored
I'm going to have to buy a second stream
deck so my olds can play it on his own
device I can finally reclaim my deck
from him I finished the main story
how is it on the stream deck
foreign
I'm just going to do the main quest
Professor Weasley's assignment
thank you
can we go out kamigawa seriously though
enjoy your videos I completed this game
twice loads of fun which houses did you
play
I've had a couple of status throughout
the entire play through default settings
oh good
it's not too bad then
how old was I when I read the first book
film asks Jim
um
I don't know I think I was eight
eight nine something like that
it was a gift from my grandfather
first book that's what got me into it
so this is
revelio
I've already done this
oh there it is
thank you
you've done Gryffindor and Hufflepuff
nice
the design of Hogwarts itself getting
busy exploring a good couple of hours
yeah lots to explore
hello IMAX
um hoof nuvin is that how you say your
name
um okay yeah I'll use some more of that
music I still have it I still use it
sometimes just not all the time
oh
you guys enjoy the stream please give it
a like
thank you thank you
what do you guys think of the uh the
outfit
one to ten
I don't think I'd change a thing
thank you 11 10.
drip
uh yeah I'm in Slytherin I'm happy
that's the house I got the last time I
took the test
Severus Clause I want to know did you
wait for this content so you don't spoil
no I've just been taking my time I mean
I guess that's another aspect I wouldn't
intentionally spoil anything because I
know people are still waiting for the
game on other consoles
it's no rush
with someone like black in charge
perhaps now Creole girl would you be
interested in JK Rowling decide to write
stories about the Wizarding World that
wasn't related to Harry Potter or any of
the characters featured in those stories
I read um
was it Casual Vacancy
what's that Casual Vacancy I can't even
remember the name
yeah I read the Casual Vacancy
um it was okay
it wasn't wasn't so much for me
that book Professor Weasley asked me to
find should be around here somewhere
uh is this where I go
let's do this
there we go that's easier right
running around collecting field guides
is a bit of a boring Quest To be honest
with you
but Professor Weasley
Transfiguration
Professor Weasley asked me to uh get
something from that book
may I have it did she now oh well I'll
give you this book if you Humor Me by
answering a few questions from my quiz
quiz some people call bits of knowledge
trivia hence I have created none of the
other students will ah they don't van
if that's the only way I can convince
you to give me that book then let's get
it over with
again before the invention of the golden
snitch which a magical creature was used
in a game of Quidditch
you know do you guys know the answer
I think it's the snidget
yes the snidget right
the Golden Corral
correct was first
covered this in a video Once that's the
only reason
which potion is commonly referred to as
liquid Felix felices
Felix felicis done since I've been to
make the Drinker temporarily lucky so
that was easy
competitions the tale of the Three
Brothers
magical artists
the Deathly Hallows correct
according to Beetle The Bard but if you
hadn't read the books and watched the
films you wouldn't know the resurrection
Stone and the
and the visibility
the largest
it's the uh the quaffle
the quaffle that's right
when a chaser
Chase of three Hoops in a quidditch
match their team is awarded 10 points
all false apologies potion allows the
Drinker to change species
no it's just
yeah no it's not like you're a um
metamorph Magus no false correct while
Polyjuice Potion can be used to change
things such as age or race it cannot be
used to change species well I suppose
this has gone on long enough I'll put
the book back on the pedestal now
how did everyone else do on it I have
plenty more questions
and I won't be giving you any more easy
I don't have time for a quiz at the
moment me know if you change your mind
I put the book back on the pedestal for
you revealia ought to make quick work of
this
that's the wheeze these toes kind of a
fun question I guess it's a 10
Transfiguration
do you guys want the other quiz
you don't have to do it do you
guys want the quiz
type one if you want the quiz two if I
should do something else
you want the quiz okay
let's do it
do you guys want to engage
with this like should I wait a minute to
answer them so that you can
you can have your own answers
I'd like to do that some more questions
what governmental body directly preceded
the ministry of magic
was the um
you know the answer do you guys know
the Wizards Council that
disbanded in 17. covered everything
she's asked in videos so for
international stuff
I'm Gonna Leave 30 seconds before I
answer them dragon breed is the smallest
I know the answer
the antipodian opolai the Peruvian Viper
tooth or the Ukrainian iron belly
[Music]
don't type the answers because
because then uh it'll give it away
the Peruvian Viper tooth brilliant
though the Viper tooth is a small
I've done a video on all the dragon
sizes as well it's also the fastest
route and feared for its venomous fangs
who founded the village of hogsmead
I know this one too
don't don't write the answer
okay I'm gonna answer now
hangist of Woodcroft that's right
It is believed that henges used the
three broomsticks in as his home the
hide behind was accidentally created by
crossbreeding a ghoul with what other
magical creature
do you guys know this one
a demi guys
while the high
EST maybe the devs
watch my videos
what is the only spell known to repel a
leatherfold
[Music]
you got this one wrong
yeah I mean they're very similar to
Dementors so
the Patronus charm well
well only known Survivor of a
leatherfold attack we've done a video on
this guys
[Music]
yeah Gump that's it one of
them's law is that food cannot be
conjured
can be some
translate to never tickle a sleeping
dragon
a particular sleeping dragon
too quick again sorry the whole
[Music]
creature is the only one known to
produce eggs through its mouth
um
it's not it's not bad for the risk
it's not Ash window must be the Rune
Spore
right
I think it's runesport
the Rune Spore that's right according to
mouth completely confident three heads
serves a different function the left
head is the planner the middle is the
dreamer and the right is the critic a
true sighted
craft and Wizardry located
it's uh
I know where it is I'm not going to tell
it tell you guys
hmm
how's everyone doing has everyone gotten
all the answers correct which ones do
you get wrong maybe I'll ask at the end
Mount Greylock done the American school
was founded in the 17th century I saw
you on uh Star Wars theories Stream True
sighted what is the most powerful love
potion kind
I'm attentia
the answer
smells differently to every person
find attractive of what did Hermione
smell when she smelled hamiltonship can
you guys answer that hanging on to the
next round
they're my most different
you guys know
she smelled two things
yeah you pretty much got it
spearmint and grass
should we do more of these I'm afraid
I'm gonna get one wrong on the stream
that'd be embarrassing
did everyone do all of these
[Music]
okay this is uh I'm taking a risk here
I think I've done I think I've proven
I'm a relative expert already
give me a worst
but was killed in a jewel against oh
this was to do with the um
the Elder one to the path of the
uh
Emerick the evil had the Elder Wand and
he was killed
by Egbert the egregious
but the egregious I did a video on this
I've done a video on everything so far
Elder Wand if a chaser keeps their hand
on the quaffle as it goes through the
goal what foul are they committing
blanching
blotching the answer was actually
happening oh no blatching is flying
through spiritually collide with a
player
switching yeah
so that her third Chaser can score a
bite from a mackled Mana claw has the
unusual side effect of causing what
damn one wrong
[Music]
a bite from a Mac called malikle has the
unusual side effect of causing Watts
webbed feet bad luck areas bad luck bad
luck
I can't believe I got one wrong
Coastline the effects of a malachor's
bite can last up to a week what plant
excrete stinks up
what plant excretes stink sap mimbulous
mabletonia flux weed supopharus Bean the
popher's pain
rememberless mimbletonia
because some of the videos I've done
were years ago
the pepper up potion evolved from a
remedy I just did a video on this
recently wizard
um it was uh Linford of stinchcomb he
was um the founding patriarch of the
Potter family also known as the Potter
lenford of stinchcombe
that's uh why Harry has so much money
what
in the Wizard and the hopping Port what
does the Elder wizard leave for his son
in the hopping pot
[Music]
in the wizard in the hopping pot was the
Elder wizard leave for her son in the
hopping pot a single slipper is one or a
smaller pot
it's a slipper I believe
a single slipper yep the story was
created by this quizzes but there are a
few quite difficult I must say I won't
spoil what the slipper was for if you
haven't read it recently
snallygaster is native to which region
of the world
I don't know uh
it's not Scotland it's not the Amazon
it does sound no it's not I think it's
North America
but I don't know this this is a guess
this one guys
um the
- oh I've done videos
who is the Muggle Knight featured in the
fountain of fair Fortune
um who is the Muggle Knight featured in
the fountain of fair Fortune sir am so
luck with sir Lancelot
it is Sir
buckless
sir luckless
yeah good the three witches in the story
are named Asha alfida and amata oh I
adore a story that ends with a Twist the
world's largest Kelpie is also known by
what are the name
isn't it the Loch Ness Loch nist
Loch Ness Monster
[Music]
yeah this is in Fantastic Beasts isn't
it
the Loch Ness monster correct
Infamous has worked
still credit any struggle evidence of
The Kelpies like that integration who
was
who I've done a video on this
um
I think it's gamp isn't it
yeah it was gamp and he's the one who to
Camp who um established gamp's law of
transfiguration you look Gump
the department of magical law
enforcement that's true he did that
outlawed the unforgivable curses
answered all of my questions
astonished by how well you did you have
a talent for trivia thank you for
humoring me that's all the levels I have
how many questions was that in total
[Music]
which ones did uh you guys get wrong
it's amazing how much I've learned just
over the course of having this channel
like when I started the channel I knew a
lot but
I wouldn't have done that well
absolutely no chance
Star Wars theory in the chat
oh no everyone uh
Star Wars theory in the chat say hello
type one if you've seen Magic Mike XXL
that Star Wars series favorite movie
foreign
Star Wars Theory
with the Super Chat 5.50 thank you very
much where's your camera
um it's
it's in the shop
settle down settle down
Transfiguration as you may be weary of
hearing me say is an exact science that
can take a lifetime to master
but we need to be done
almost anything can be transformed if
you can just perceive the potential
within it as I see I don't have Defender
[Music]
it could just be my eyesight
and in the castle pretty well now I
don't use fast travel tool anymore oh I
didn't know the castle uh not that well
to be honest
beautifully done you guys want the game
volume up
yeah we have a similar sounding voice
yeah mine's just a few octaves deeper
than his that's the easiest way to
distinguish them
discussed my progress so far I can do an
impression of him I did you seem to have
had no trouble in getting up to speed
and frankly
excelling in your schoolwork this year
I'm glad to hear it I'm not certain I
needed all the extra assignments and I'm
certain you would not have been a
successful without them
oh it seems you've been making good use
of the opportunities presented by your
field guide of course the guide isn't
the only measure of success I've heard
that you can bring yeah I need to do the
quest to learn
hopefully you won't need it anytime soon
but it is a valuable potion to have when
it is needed thank you Professor I will
say I'm especially impressed with all
you've accomplished in light of the
rumors of your
extracurricular activities where your
meetings with Professor Black's house
elf and exploration of various caves
down by the lake connected in any way to
Professor thing yeah Star Wars Theory
sounds like me when I was 12. that's the
best way to distinguish us
like a much smaller weaker version
I've learned crucio I haven't learned
the other ones yet
I want to do that Quest soon
not at all I was uh intrigued by stories
of a giant squid and wanted to Professor
Weasley is a snake encountered scrope
who seemed delighted to share what he
knew I see I admire your ponchon for
learning but
for class work and
guide our desire
end of the year in no time hey everyone
say uh Happy Birthday to Star Wars
Theory
until then
well done you are dismissed
laughs
oh no
since our visit to felcroft oh here's
Sebastian meet me at the overlook this
looks like uh and I'll explain a quest
for an unforgivable curse I believe
my plan with the helmet failed
that's crucia
nice how sweet
yeah how uh what level are you now how
far away are you from
try to lack
okay let's go to this Sebastian Quest
looks interesting
yeah you better get back to it okay
[Music]
thanks Ryan
ah upper hogsfield now where to find Mrs
brothel
actually I'm gonna sell some stuff
before we go any further
yeah okay you've made up a hogsfield
safe
must have just sold everything marvelous
I could always use more of these
marvelous
thank you for passing through
bet
who's this
Professor garlic is sus
ah
I'm excited for this class it's getting
worse
if there is any chance that the Relic
from slytherin's Spellbook can help her
I must find it
I'm requesting your help
meet me outside of feldcroft near the
category I came as soon as I could I've
been so Star Wars Theory says Professor
garlic can get it
gpg says
this is the view painted on the canvas
that was left on it that's incredible
you know this area well and while I was
waiting
abandoned mine nearby surrounded by
randwick's loyalists do you think
there's a connection to the triptych I
have no idea but perhaps they're
searching it the way they did Brookwood
castle and his adora's Manor who do you
guys prefer Professor garlic or
Professor sprouts
we need to see what they're doing them
head on let's bury some enemies very
well and I still have that Rune symbol
we found on the triptych you look the
scars that is the connection I suspect
we'll see that symbol again
after you
high maintenance friend he keeps asking
me to meet him like 10 miles outside of
the school there they are up ahead
I'll let you lead
oh it's gonna be nice
kill anyone who tries
kill spells
I've been fighting since before you were
born
Rusty
that was not what I meant to equip
ment
that wasn't very smooth but I got the
job done
I love confringo confringos I mean
I think it's technically supposed to be
more powerful than this in the real
Harry Potter world I mean
if you if you do make a distinction
asking render driver to make a new
Banner for us if you want to send a
photo okay I'll do that uh after this
cool
that we got here
I wonder why Aurora never seemed to wear
armor into the ministry purchase those
Enchanted House people in the field
you know you're getting better at this
that block was near perfect thank you
you thank you
I didn't I don't think I did well there
but
I kept Miss clicking buttons
this is going well
we make a good team
we do what that's once again we can
fight our way through or be discreet
who's this
you don't
like potato
ES
too easy
too easy it is and that was relatively
Frozen confringo and defindo I don't
have defindo yet I should do the quest
does it uh quite powerful
fighting goblins is like fighting a
vacuum
where do you think they could take the
sequel of the game
um I'd like for them to add more schools
so you can explore um you know wagadu
where um onai is from
uh maybe ilver morning places like that
I'd like a quidditch DLC which I think
will happen given there's already a
quidditch pitch I'd like Diagon Alley
um I don't know what do you guys want
what would you like to see
I should tell you rumor is this mine was
closed long ago due to an infestation of
spiders oh nice spiders nothing I
haven't seen before
that's the spirit
all right let's do it Australian
Wizarding School apparently there is an
Australian visiting school
um but there hasn't been anything
released on it but it has been confirmed
that that exists
I think maybe she'll release something
on that eventually
no I haven't spoken with garlic yet
this mine looks like a tomb it was
closed after accidents were reported
now I see why snow door School Online
PVP with the ranking system yeah that'd
be cool
Defender slaps are
quidditch as online multiplayer yeah but
they'd have that would be complicated to
add but
Lucas did you know about the Australian
Wizarding School
Nicola says loving your beards one
Isaiah during The Wizarding war between
our character when Harry was a baby
one during the wizardy war between our
character oh yeah that'd be cool
which Quest am I doing
um it is called
in the shadow of the Mind
did the centaurs run the Train on
Umbridge
I've seen people have records in these
webs
disgusting for even a spider to press
[Music]
too many they definitely think there's
something here they want
what else have we got
um I like high level cap more spells a
better talent tree yeah higher level cap
that'll happen I think
uh
look at me showing off yeah
no it's not on hard
I'm gonna just gradually I'm gonna play
through again in a different house on a
higher difficulty
but it's awfully High
100 times Rebellion you know
okay well
whoops that's the wrong spell
s
the Dynamics of climbing onto things
sometimes doesn't make any sense
have you guys noticed that
yes
sometimes it could be the hairy legs
randomly or solar size or the venomous
things
endearing qualities really
oh here we go
should have thought to conjure stairs
Rebellion
I have to repair some stuff here
I like repair a lot
one of the coolest looking spells
meeting first here Dumbledore yeah I
mean
we're just a few years shy of Dumbledore
coming to Hogwarts so
Rebellion
I wish you weren't able to change the
appearance of things because
then it would be more of a challenge to
try and source strong items that look a
certain way I don't like that you can
just change it however you want it's too
easy
two spoon fed
what do you guys think
yeah I know Sebastian has all the Spells
I do but he waits for me good
charming school cloak
let's have a look
oh not a high enough level apparently
uh where was I going rebellio I guess I
should go up here
oh who's this
can be too easy to watch
the way
that was cool though
thank you
we've read the world of another spot I'm
at the beginning we'll catch up
anyone knows at the end of any dialogue
NPC's faces go totally Dead uh maybe a
little bit
I think I'll leave I have the last day
of my exam I want to watch and leave a
like keep going by thanks to lack thanks
for coming by
um is Professor black related to Syria
same question for Professor Weasley and
Ron Yep they're all related
um yeah man black is Phineas nigellous
black
who's sirius's grandfather I believe
grandfather great grandfather I think
grandfather
I shall sleep better tonight revelio
well we're making quick work of them
Professor Heckert will be I don't want
to see it Valiant she wouldn't that
run rocks
I need
me some lumos lumos lumos
I didn't take any damage from any of
those fights and then I got
damaged by venomous tentacular
oh no that's not what this is it's uh
what's it called isn't it is it venomous
tentacular
I can't think of the name right now
I'm blanking
devil snare that's it yeah yeah of
course
I knew that
oh God
um have I done any videos on love Goods
um
I think I've done a few nothing
really in depth
we've still not seen a single Rune
symbol I think we're going to be a bit
distracted from runes for a moment
an unwelcome distraction at that I'm
watching the movies right now why does
serious want to kill Harry and then they
become friends he doesn't want to kill
Harry he's trying to protect Harry he's
Harry's Godfather
they just think he's evil because he
went to Azkaban and Harry doesn't know
the truth
because he was framed by Pettigrew
we have another fight recently came back
from a band surprised
everything
oh he stopped
I didn't do anything
that was tough rebellious
certainly cleared the room I used a
little bit of white gryffindors get
credit for bravery we Slither into
teeming with it okay let me read the
channel
ruse yes he busted in that room and says
to Wolfgang let's kill him uh they're
referring to piece of Pettigrew who is
disguised as scabbers whose Ron's pet
rat that's who they're talking about
they're not going to kill Harry they're
talking about the rat that Ron's holding
um
what if you can make guns that work the
same as ones I did a video on why they
don't use guns you should watch it
more voices yeah that'd be cool
um favorite one Half Blood Prince
favorite book or film
I know the book the film wasn't
particularly popular but I like it
uh don't forget I have ancient magic
yeah
okay
those fires are tough
Rebellion
we can have a look around in peace yeah
you bet that's what I'm here for
um
oh
revelio
okay I'm assuming I have to
move this somewhere
foreign
incendio
sempra considered dark magic yeah
Rebellion
foreign
I wouldn't be surprised to find a couple
more Rune symbols
and they're more um
symbol somewhere must be
yourself
huh
this looks like where I'm supposed to go
no
is this where I go
these rooms must be connected somehow
try casting at them more quickly
wasn't expecting that
oh down there okay
I thought I um hit them quick enough
so I've played 21 hours that's it
revelio
the world floated back to me as if in a
watery Haze how long had I been
unconscious I only remember his eyes
empty empty of Sorrow yes but also a
recall feeling a sense of euphoria as I
watched the pain vanish then everything
started to turn when I fell I must have
hit my head I knew the feel nor see a
mark but the pain is throbbing I can
only hope it is not the black death at
least he is no longer in pain
what do you have there a journal entry
by Isadora hopefully it will help us
unravel more of this mystery
Christine no this is going to be a
rebellion
something lumos
Sebastian I think I found something I
think a canvas piece
brilliant our efforts weren't in vain
after all
still
something about this place feels odd
obviously gonna go this way
right okay nope
Rebellion
oh check on Sebastian
tryptic led us here to find this bit of
canvas we can probably assume you guys
like the stream please give it a like
she seems to have been everywhere but if
she was using the undercraft and the
seller beneath her Manor and feldcraft
why would she create this space and why
hide it behind cryptic Rune symbols and
ancient magic that no one but you could
see is Adora and Percival Rackham
another of the keepers could see traces
of ancient magic too raccoon
haven't heard his name before his are
some of the memories I've seen I put a
poll up on the channel today
on how this match are asking for video
requests so if anyone has any video
requests or suggestions
after this of course the place is odd to
be sure
but I'm fascinated by it now for the
Trek back out of here
the undercroft okay
and now for the moments of Truth
it has to fit
please tell me you recognize the
location in this bit of canvas
the good news is I do in fact hi pan
torture bad news we're in for more
trouble
why do I talk over dialogue
I don't know man
if you don't want talking over the
dialogue
I think you should just play
[Music]
it would be cool if there's a half blood
in Harry Potter who brought Muggles and
wizards together
like what people think grogu might be
yeah
yeah that'd be cool
where is Sebastian
oh he's there
[Music]
um
is this bugged it says talk to Sebastian
Rebellion
what is this
what's going on do I have to leave
I don't understand what's happening
Rebellion
[Music]
uh uh this is the exit right
I can't leave
what do I do do I save and then come
back
yeah that's a good idea
um am I disappointed with the
cancellation of the Fantastic Beasts
Trilogy asks Lucas uh yeah I am I don't
know I mean I don't know if it's
completely canceled
it looks like it
but I don't know for certain
oh this is so annoying
um let me look it up
Hogwarts
Legacy bug stuck under Croft
that's annoying
um okay I'm gonna just
hi Lauren
I saved recently I think didn't I
yeah I shade I remember I saved here
let's do this
I think this will work right and now for
the moments of Truth
it has to fit okay here we go please
work
please tell me you recognize the
location in this bit of canvas the good
news is I do in fact
and the bad surprise that hasn't been
patched we're in for more trouble
okay oh works this time I know that
Coast Round Rock has taken over a huge
mine in the surrounding area Marin wien
has suffered for it
it's as bad as feldcroft's become should
we head there now we should wait why all
this time we've been a step behind run
Rock
I may know someone who could help us get
ahead who is that
a friendly Goblin he wants no part in
Ran Rock's fight a friendly Goblin you
know goblins cursed my sister to shut
her up said she should be seen and not
heard I do but not all goblins not all
goblins what
have you forgotten no Sebastian I
haven't you're not list why would I
listen to someone so ignorant thanks
ruse
you don't know what you're saying take a
breath for a moment oh I know precise
unbelievable oh
foreign
[Music]
what's this new Quest
is this the one
Bro went full racism yeah bro needs to
chill for real
so basically get some reasonable quickly
he does isn't he he's a little baby
horrible at navigating still
oh I should go to the room of uh
requirement
it's around here isn't it
hey Jonathan Levin I'm good how are you
oh
Perla you have a good point
hello there
well this is not what I want oh no it is
what I want hello there
hello all mate do I recall you saying
that you speak gopity cook I did I mean
I do
speak it
is this to do with the goblin I saw you
with and you guys like amazing
his name is lodgok
we could use your help with something
he's waiting for me near a goblin mind
would you be willing to help of course
how exciting I mean
might this be dangerous I think he
simply wants to show me something
if it helps he's a friend of seromas
good to hear good to hear if sirona
trusts him then I feel much better
Lord God is waiting should we go of
course
just want to check the pronunciation of
a couple of terms first so I will meet
you there
Rebellion
oh level up
level up
there's nothing wrong with being uh
geek
[Music]
okay let's go to this mine
oh it's not letting me
how far away is this mine
mine goodness
is there any reason to do all of the
trials of Merlin
now or can I just do those later on
I wish you could enable passive rebellio
a wonderful Wizards with thick accent
with films and spells it's more about
the intent so probably not
a friend who speaks gobbledygook is
meeting us before he arrives oh really
perhaps you could tell how many slots
unfortunately presenting run rock with
the help did not have the effect I'd
hoped because he knew the details
surrounding its plunder he presumed I'd
had help from a witch or wizard in
retrieving it
you said this would repair the chasm
between the two of you hold on a sec
just expect him to react this way I'm
afraid we do not have the luxury of
rational expectation when it comes to
ran Rock damn bragbor in his black gpg
says what about when Lupine teaches
ridiculous what about it renowned metal
worker if we are to work together I
suppose I must tell you more not long
ago ranrock sent me to collect a
recently Unearthed set of braggboar's
journals they describe repositories that
bragbor had been commissioned to build
for there are 100 trials of Merlin what
do you mean repositories large magically
fortified receptacles crafted from
Goblin metal ranrock recruited others to
help me locate the repositories we were
to search anywhere that was connected to
five names mentioned in the journals
Rackham Fitzgerald Picard morganock and
Rookwood
that is where we began us why does Round
Rock care he cares about for centuries
Wizards have refused to share their
magical knowledge with goblins yeah
they're not quite different well not
even let us carry ones this stimulates
thus many goblins myself included have
spent our lives mistrusting wizard kind
I wish some of the trials that the
Republican monster But Here Comes My
friend I'll meet problem
greetings Lord it is an honor sir
you speak gobbledygook
[Music]
enough
please do not tell me that was meant to
be gobbled again
I am well yes perhaps my pronunciation
was a bit off I imagine certain dialects
differ
pronunciation is not the issue I barely
recognize that as language
I trust you can read gobbledygook better
than you can speak it I can sir not
what written plans
we need some idea of what ran Rock knows
or is plotting I suspect a careless
loyalist may have left and I'm unable to
join you before all you need to do is
not
Silas you should make a video on the
Founder's family for the little kids and
grandchildren I love all your videos bro
since day one I'm a fan never miss any
of them bro thank you Anthony yeah um I
am planning on doing videos on the
Bloodlines of the founders so that'll
cover that
I'll meet and I can do this and thank
you again
I shall see you soon
it'd be cool to learn one of the Harry
Potter languages I could do tutorial
videos if I learn it myself
I'm gonna go get this uh
Blue Point here
is this the trial of Merlin okay I'll do
this one since I'm here
okay
what is this one revelio
oh this thing
whoops oh no did you go down the hill
oh no
foreign
love yourself
what do I do
I don't think I can do it
won't come up the hill
do I have to go down and use the Pulsa
maybe should I come back to this because
I can't go far away from the quest
that was bad timing I don't know why I
did that
I almost have it but if I
travel too far away from the quest and
it won't let me finish
I don't think it's meant to go down the
hill it's supposed to go here
oh is that it again oh it came back
good
okay so I'll go up
oh no
okay I give up what did I do
oh he's there okay it doesn't I'm gonna
do it later on anyway hold on a second
it's loud in the hallway in my building
I'm just gonna mute myself for a sec
beautiful
okay I'm back
Rebellion
is that to get into the mine
or was that for the trial of Merlin
uh
uh okay okay thank you what would I do
without you
um
sneaking about you'll see
I don't have a sneak around while I'm in
here do I books
[Music]
rebellio
I cannot believe I met a goblin
a device
impressive workmanship aside it's the
only way forward
am I going to use all this gold at some
point
rebellious
just doing amassing gold in cartoon I
haven't used it
Rebellion
is that it
I've read about minds like this
you need to be careful because I'm sure
you know
foreign
later some of these puzzles were
actually kind of tricky if I upgrade my
broom
um I might have upgraded it once what
are the upgrades speed
duration of boosting
I'll get us through
his I have my word
this is cool
they're being watched
by a door
speed handling and acceleration okay
Perler pitch a video on things like Lord
of the Rings franchise in The Wizarding
World have in common like magic
obviously gobbins in mind the kind of
blind main character Etc I mean they're
both
incredibly inspired by mythology Lord of
the Rings
and hope to the copies Lord of the Rings
I've done a video comparing the magic of
Both Worlds before
but unfortunately those comparison
videos really don't do well
no one's most people don't seem to care
I feel like a character from one of the
adventure books I read during the summer
holidays
yeah
let's take a look around
see them find any plans
I will get to the bottom of what they've
been building down here
revelio
go back where what are you saying why
back here
[Music]
fascinating to see Goblin oh in the
other room oh okay cool yeah I'll go
there flourishes are extraordinary let
me know if you see any more plans or
schematics we can't return to lodgok
empty headed
if I'm translating this correctly wait
what is behind the Watergate is that uh
just a scroll but what
it's around here why could they be
building
it seems like the way to go thanks true
sighted
oh my God
this way
groundbreaking
oh this really is too much
stay close
another boiler
what else have we got here we've got
Rachel Kearns 86 hello hope you're doing
well hope you're doing well Rachel
thanks for joining
Mr animation what quest am I on I am
doing it's all gobbledygook the main
quest
how does incendio not affect your own
character close range
slamming humans I know it's a sweet
sweet spell rebelio
I'll jump up there
Crimson quinnage gloves
another schematic what are they going to
build this mine is too small for
whatever it is revelio
uh am I a doctor who fan
um I mean
somewhat I've watched some of the older
ones and I watched some of Doctor Who
with David Tennant
and who is that singer that did Doctor
Who with David Tennant
foreign
actress
now watch that
a long time ago
couldn't bring them
really quickly yeah yeah that's it
it's been a while
it was good it's a shame that Davidson
stopped
because he didn't want to be Typecast
right because she kind of was
Kylie Minogue was in it Devil's slab
nasty stuff
not an entanglement
laughs
gets me every time
oh lumos
lumos
Anthony roach did I see your question
about the households oh
no I didn't
um Silas do you think we'll do a video
on how on how Wizarding families own
househelves from the beginning because I
never understood how Wizarding family
owned one please uh
I think I've done a video on that before
I did a video it's called why are house
shelves enslaved if they're so powerful
and a lot of the history on the house
elves and wizard ownership is in that
video so you should watch that if you
haven't
yeah I usually sell the stuff
but I haven't been to a shop
since I started this Quest
the Wizards will be defeated
oh goodness
crazy
a message
so many goblins
what's up
incentives
cool down
thank you
my goodness that was difficult
it always bugged me how Harry did lumos
Maximus and third move without any
consequence
oh like in in on privet Drive yeah
uh would I be open to writing my own
novels
um maybe in the future I don't know no
I'm not there yet
that was difficult my goodness
thank you true science for believing in
me
it's one that adds some spells back to
the game that didn't make it to release
like fiend fire obliviate and confronto
cool fiend fire would be that should be
the last time
that was quite tough I think it might be
the toughest fight I've had in this game
what ad did you guys get
do ants normally run on these
missing anything
okay Let's uh run away
of course
how do you upgrade ancient Magic
foreign
points
which um
slot is the ancient magic is that in
core or
what's this
oh this is useful right
should I get this one too
yeah
this one
yes no
what do you think
is a bombardo a good spell like should I
replace one of my main
one of the spells in my man my main
rotation with bombardo
I haven't really used it to be honest
yeah
is this worth it
what do you think
hold on in just a second guys
bear with me
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna upgrade
bombardo and I'm gonna start using it
yeah Talent Point anxiety
um
okay so I'm gonna get rid of
incendio
oh no
okay let's get rid of some stuff some
trash
blue four eye spectacles
I kind of like this one more with the
confringo damage I'm gonna keep these
PlayStation grows I got a PlayStation
just for this game you know that
Rebellion
as long as you like the vids that's okay
that must be a quicker way out of it and
retracing our steps
purple
foreign
it is isn't it
lumos lumos revelio
okay let's look at the comments
I'll explain almost as the best spell
against which or Wizards if they can't
do magic without a wand well one this
magic exists still
especially like I mean that we're going
to the Wizarding school that
Professor onai is from they don't use
ones
uh
uh when you get that perk that turns the
enemies into a barrel Transfiguration
slays actually game changing
why did they change wingardium aviosa to
levioso they're a bit different
I know your pages about Harry Potter law
but what you cut would you cover are the
popular laws in the future yeah maybe
maybe
I have a mythology Channel as well that
I run with a friend called mythology
explained so he voices them now um I
voiced over a hundred of them though
there's no best house they all have
there
you know they'll have um
positives and negatives so
up to your opinion
why am I lost I don't know where I'm
going full
back here
where am I going guys
what do I do
oh this is it okay
the
so a lore question I was thinking about
if Goblin silver absorbed if Goblin
silver absorbs positive effects it comes
in contact with if you polish The Sword
of Gryffindor with liquid luck would it
be forever lucky
I didn't think it would I don't think
the potion would last that long still
but maybe temporarily if you wielded the
sword you'd be lucky
um thoughts on blood purity
blood charity shouldn't matter
nifola thanks for following my other
page
yeah why do they make it so easy to why
do they make it so difficult to uh
this place
right
that a meat oh
[Music]
that's the last loyalist
unfortunate really
I'd imagine most goblins to be brilliant
and kind
Rebellion
um generic videos what platform are you
playing on and playing on PS5
lead farmer just join what house are you
a member of I'm in Slytherin favorite
character Dumbledore or Snape
um no I haven't done a video on the
history of Gringotts
done done a lot of history videos though
I don't know why they made it difficult
to leave this place
no sense
can we please talk about that wasn't so
bad was it it was was there a difference
list I was supposed to take I'm afraid
I've had enough adventure for one day
for a lifetime perhaps thank you Amit I
can understood your Goblin secrets are
without further ado had you and you
um
do I want them to continue Fantastic
Beasts or would I prefer they move on to
something else
um
I'd like them to continue Fantastic
Beasts
and if they do something else I'd like
them to really take their time with it
Henry Awakening goodnight thanks for
stopping by
they're building enormous drills we
found their plans Round Rock must be
searching for the repositories I fear
you are correct
other than Rookwood Castle however I do
not know where else who plans to search
I've been wondering about something else
you said before we entered the mine yes
if you share ran Rock's views then why
are you helping me
I expected Rookwood Castle to be
deserted when I arrived to begin my
search
so it was surprised to find
a witch there who would set up a sort of
improvised research site
she was studying something so intently
that she almost didn't notice me
when she looked up
I thought she would react with fear
or disdain
but instead she did something that I
will never forget
without a moment's hesitation
and asked me to sit with her
she told me that she was a researcher
and showed me a small
oddly shaped container with the strange
symbol on it
she was certain it was made of goblin
metal but was unable to open it
she wanted to work together
Miriam
yes
but how did you profess a fake's wife
he told me of her research and I know of
the container
Perla says I've been using your videos
to relax and or fall asleep for over a
year thank you for watching goblins
intelligence and skill it caught me
entirely off guard
I'd never been treated with such Respect
by a witch or wizard
so to my surprise
I let her study the container if she
would allow me no you can't make it on
my own
we parted ways with her promising to
share what she'd learned
hmm
more of ran Rock's recruits arrived and
we began to dig eventually locating the
first Repository
ranrock was thrilled with our discovery
but Furious what I told him about Miriam
berated me for trusting a witch
and I heard she'd been killed
you think Ryan Rock murdered her
I don't want to believe it
but
I don't know
after that something shifted in me
he's a good Storyteller I had seen how
the power from the repositories was
transforming ranrock transforming all of
them
I could no longer remain
thank you Lord for telling me this
tell you all of this
so that you understand what is at stake
Round Rock never found all of
blackboard's journals
but the ones he did find suggest that
Bradmore at some point built a
repository farther in size than the one
beneath Rookwood Castle
which you've discovered here today
worries me deeply
if Round Rock learns from the location
of that Repository
I fear we shall be destined for a great
War
knows
watch for my owl
I bet he dies I don't know if he dies
this is a total guess but a petty dies
yeah good voice actor for sure
[Music]
okay guys I'm done for now
um but I'll be back in a couple of days
maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow or the
next day
thank you to everyone for tuning in
for the help
I hope everyone has a good rest of the
day or night or wherever you are
you bet okay see you guys
thank you